joining me now for reaction is
representative trey gowdy he's the
chairman of the House Oversight
Committee a committee I used to chair
he's on the intelligence committees on
the Judiciary Committee is on the ethics
committee and rumor has it he's actually
the chairman of the 4-h club there at
Capitol Hill he joins us from Greenville
South Carolina and for Dallas
Congressman John Ratcliffe he serves on
the House Judiciary Committee and
homeland security committee where he is
the subcommittee chair on cybersecurity
he's a former United States prosecutor
gentlemen happy holidays Merry Christmas
Happy New Year and thank you so much for
joining us congressman Gowdy I want to
start with you because I've actually
been in your seat I've dealt with the
Department of Justice when they're not
responsive but how bad is the situation
what are the documents that you need
particularly in the Intel committee in
order to get the job done that you want
to get done well happy new year to you
Jason and you too Johnny
Jason as you know investigations are
only as good as your access to documents
and witnesses in this case we need water
call 302s when the FBI interviews
someone a 302 that is the name of the
forum that is generated we also need
what's called 1020 threes which is a
another summary of an interaction
between an FBI agent and a source so we
need all of that so we can then prepare
to interview whether it's a former
general counsel Baker or whether it is
Peter stroke whether it's Lisa page we
need to interview everyone who may have
access to information and we need access
to all the documents and frankly Jason
we've been waiting a long time for it as
you know I used to work for the
Department of Justice as did Johnny if I
have a bias at all it is towards them
they need to produce the witnesses and
the information this is taken longer
that it then it should and and longer
than it needs to so congressman
Ratcliffe you've been a United States
prosecutor and to use a famous line what
difference does it make I mean part of
what's happening is the Intel committee
has been looking at the the rush so
called Russia probe but you're on the
Judiciary Committee the Judiciary
Committee has come together with the
Oversight Committee and there
looking at things that have nothing to
do with a Russia investigation but do
have things to do with how the
Department of Justice has acted now you
were in the room in you and trey gowdy
were the two that got to actually
interview mr. mchabe how did that go
was he forthright and who do you need to
interview him interview next well Jason
good to be with you chairman Gowdy
always a pleasure listen the reason that
we had a former or the Deputy Director
Andrew McCabe in the room really related
to the prior testimony a former director
James Comey Jason you and chairman Gowdy
and myself were all in the room when he
testified in fatica Lee and
unequivocally that the decision to
prosecute or not to prosecute Hillary
Clinton had been made after her July 2nd
interview with the FBI and then we
subsequently learned of a May 2nd memo
written by the former director Comey
himself that went through multiple
rounds of edits with people at the FBI
where it appears that that decision had
in fact been made two months before her
interview had been conducted so was
those types of decisions that were out
of or out of the ordinary at the FBI
that really prompted the need for an
investigation into these matters and
really what what the investigation that
you just referenced involving the ogr
committee and the Judiciary Committee is
really to get answers to those questions
that I think the American people have
long sought so now that you've heard
that testimony congressman Ratcliffe who
do you need to interview next who's who
are you going to bring in to do those
transcribed interviews well ultimately
the with the interview that took place
two weeks ago was a confidential
interview I would describe it as a
foundational interview with deputy
director McCabe it really did ask
questions about who what when where with
respect to a lot of these decisions that
were made at the FBI and the Department
of Justice as well that we're out of the
ordinary or out of standard protocol and
so really he was able to provide us with
a number of answers that will be helpful
in identifying the people that we need
to talk to he also was not able to
provide substantive answers to some
other questions so we'll continue this
process ultimately I think chairman
Gowdy and I agree that we'd like to see
former director Comey come and maybe
attorney general Lynch come in to answer
some of these questions because there's
a factual basis to bring them in and
give them the opportunity to clear up
what appear to be some inconsistencies
between the testimony that they've
previously given to members of Congress
and the documents that have now surfaced
you know congressman Gowdy one of the
things that strikes me about what's
happened with the Department of Justice
and specifically the FBI is so many
abnormal abnormalities things that
things would never ever happen and in
any other situation but you've both been
prosecutors what is different about the
investigation that went into Hillary
Clinton and the decision the
announcement what is that laundry list
of things that is so different than what
normally happens during these
investigations
well Jason let's say at the outset the
difficult facts make for difficult
conclusions and and 2016 was a really
difficult year for the FBI and part of
that was because of decisions they made
and part of it was because of their tiny
conducting an investigation in the
throes of a presidential race but the
short answer a question is what was
different about the investigation in the
Secretary Clinton the answer is almost
everything I'm not interested in
litigating their decision not to charge
her just forget about that you can like
it you cannot like it no entity is too
big to provide oversight over and the
FBI and the Department of Justice are
strong enough and venerable enough to
withstand scrutiny so Johnny Johnny
mentioned one point if you have made the
decision not to charge someone in May of
2016 before you have interviewed two
dozen witnesses before you have
interviewed the target of the
investigation then you're gonna have to
explain how you reach that decision not
to charge before you ended the
investigation I want to know about the
immunity agreements I want to know why
you allow fact witnesses to sit in on
witness interviews I want to know why
you wanted those witness interviews to
be voluntary you know Johnny and every
other really good prosecutor knows that
you use the grand jury to interview
witnesses you don't let the witness set
them the ground rules
and say well I'm gonna have these
friends and family in the room and we're
gonna take a break at this table that's
not the way it's done for anyone else in
this country so I want to ask the FBI
did you do things differently in her
investigation and quite frankly Jason we
already know the answer the answer is
yes so then we're gonna ask why did you
do it differently in her case and again
I think the bureau and the Department of
Justice are big enough to withstand
those questions real quickly at - both
of you maybe starting with congressman
Radcliffe the integrity of the
Department of Justice and the FBI is
under attack what do we need to do to
turn that around what needs to happen
internally there to get the confidence
of the American people back well you
know I think part of the problem that
we've been looking at here and be people
that have created the issues as chairman
Gowdy has said it's been a bad 18 months
for the Department of Justice and the
FBI some of the people that made it a
really difficult time are gone now but
there are new folks and really what
we've got to do as members of Congress
is conduct the oversight necessary to
see whether or not they're being
effective in restoring the integrity of
the Department of Justice listen I think
chairman Gowdy and I agree we hope that
the FBI and DOJ officials like former
director Comey and attorney general
Lynch we we genuinely hope that they
have plausible explanations for all of
these unprecedented circumstances that
chairman Gowdy just described we hope
that they do because if they don't then
we really are facing a constitutional
crisis we have a situation where the
American people will really question the
integrity of the FBI and the Department
of Justice for decades to come and so
you know I really hope that these
investigations that we're conducting in
our role as congressional oversight can
shed some light on that
we're not prosecutors anymore I'm not
accusing anyone of crimes neither as
chairman Gowdy but we have an oversight
role on behalf of the American people as
their elected representatives and that's
what all of these investigations at the
Congressional level are really about no
that's this country is different because
we are self-critical we do look under
the hood and see what's going on we'd
speak truth to power